beaucoup de questions
d'abord attaché à europe 1 et malgré
tout pourquoi avoir laissé entre
guillemets fils et
repeints
comme je vous disais tout à l'heure
c'est une probablement une une somme
d'erreurs
que j'assume si je doit les assumer seul
je les assumerai seul
est ce que c'est le fait d'avoir mis
trop peu d'informations parce qu'on met
davantage d'informations aujourd'hui
c'est possible est ce que il y avait
toute une génération qui est parti alors
là pour le coup non pas qu'ils ont
souhaité partir mais par l'âge
qui nous manque aujourd'hui
même si on a gardé quelques grandes voix
c'est possible aussi
le virage du numérique on a pris trop
tard c'est clair on voit d'ailleurs
maintenant le nombre croissant de gens
qui écoutent la radio avec leur mobile
et c'est une bonne chose ce virage on a
pris trop tard et je je
j'avoue que j'ai pas vu le coup passé
assez vite ça je m'en veux
et puis à un moment aussi voyez à force
de vouloir gérer au plus serré je pense
qu'on a on aurait dû investir davantage
probablement dans la dans la rédaction
probablement avec des des journalistes à
l'étranger ce qu'on n'a pas voulu faire
parce qu'on sentait déjà que les profits
commencé à diminuer diminué diminué donc
je me suis attaqué à la base de coûts ce
qui était probablement pas le bon moment
pour le faire j'ai pas été assez patient
probablement donc ça c'est aussi une
autre raison
et puis il ya eu des nouveaux entrants
et puis pardonnez moi je vais le dire
parce que je leur dis aussi en face le
csa ne nous a absolument pas aidé au
contraire alors qu'il fasse à lire qu'il
crève interpellé dessus mais quand vous
dites que le csa ne nous a pas aidés oui
alors qu'il crée un nouveau réseau je
peux comprendre ça a été le cas aussi
dans la téléphonie
ça a fait du mal aux anciens et puis
finalement tout le monde s'y retrouve et
que c'est a donc créé un réseau comme
comme rmc on en voit l'utilité
aujourd'hui dans la pluralité c'est un
grand succès bravo alain weil rien à
dire bon mais là on a perdu beaucoup de
2,2 de croissance dans les émetteurs
et puis à chaque fois je ne critique
aucune personne mais à chaque fois qu'il
y avait des autorisations qui étaient
disponibles j'ai senti alors peut-être
que je me trompe je suis prudent dans ce
que je dis mais j'ai senti qu'on était
pas vraiment favorisé voilà que le
public était davantage que nous et que
d'autres stations de radio l'était
davantage que nous voilà ça c'est le
côté un peu mauvais joueur mais je
n'utiliserai qu'une seule fois parce
qu'encore une fois je vous le dis je
vous le répète je j'assume j'assume ces
échecs bon voilà
je regrette autant que vous et c'est
pour ça que maintenant je m'attelle à
faire en sorte que les choses se passent
se passe un peu mieux
[Musique]